since he was a teenager Israeli American
naton Levy has trained to fight first in
kung fu then karate now he's a rising
star in the UFC and his most important
fight yet might still await him in his
home country of Israel I sat down with
Natan to get his thoughts on the
emerging conflict Natan thank you for
coming on the show thank you very much
for having me so Natan you are in Israel
right now you were not all that far from
the M attack when it first started and
you've been there for the last week or
more uh what are you seeing on the
ground uh over here you know I'm lucky
enough to be uh far enough which is
about 20 miles away from the where the
real atrocities
happened um where I'm staying at Sirens
uh Rockets uh the usual Israeli
stuff uh but what happened pretty close
to here was uh was pretty scary it's
amazing for you to say you know luckily
I'm far away relatively far away from
where all the atrocities happened you
know I'm 20 miles out it just drives
home for people how small this country
really is yeah it's tiny I live in Vegas
and it's the same thing 20 miles can be
a right to the gym and out here it's the
difference between life and death so
people I know friends of mine who live
in Israel are being called up uh for m
milary service especially as the war
expands you know now it's expanded from
Southern Lebanon Israel struck the
Syrian airport I mean this who knows you
this war could expand to Iran how much
of the population is being called up for
military service we have 3,00 300,000
military Reserve that's been called up
and it actually got to
0% uh who came in so more people than
got called showed up for the reserve
people who did not get called showed up
to defend their country because they
really understand right now this is our
you know a new era Independence War if
we don't win this one big time uh there
will be no Israel what what are you
predicting I mean in terms of the next
week two weeks month how long are people
in Israel expecting this war to go on
ultimately what is the objective going
to be do you think the objective is
going to be just obliterate Hamas is the
objective going to be obliterate Gaza is
the objective going to be regime change
in Iran I mean what are what are people
talking about you know I can't I can't
tell you what the military strategy is
but I can tell you the people's
sentiment for us we want a total
Destruction of
Hamas
um you know we won't stop we don't want
to stop this war until we have at least
uh anybody that's held captive and still
alive we want them back you know I see
people tweeting about
deescalation there is no deescalation
the gloves are off uh do you want us to
send them a gift card as well there is
going to be no the escalation you killed
confirmed 1300 uh people injured 3,000
people uh kidnpped more than 200 people
there is no deescalation we're going to
obliterate Hamas and and see from there
of course it's all coming from Iran
they're the enemies of the modern world
of Israel and of the US and uh you know
any free nation in in the on the planet
they want us gone they want us Dead uh
they want something completely different
in the world and they're not scared of
saying it you know people are walking
around it walking around it they're not
scared of saying it and we shouldn't be
scared to defend our country and to
defend our values our modern values uh
you know Freedom it's basic and human
rights what about Hezbollah so you know
obviously the attack from the south
comes from uh Hamas but Hezbollah then
starts attacking from the north uh will
will the war expand to obliterate
Hezbollah as well or is it really just
focused on Hamas look what happened with
Hamas uh for years again because Israel
is a mod country we don't want a war we
don't want people to die so Hamas would
launch rockets we would fire back we
would defend ourselves of course the
world and everybody on Twitter would
criticize Israel and from there you know
not because of that but just because
Israel wants to preserve life the moment
they would offer a truce we would say
yeah sure truce if you guys don't want
to kill us then we don't want to kill
you it's pretty simple but what happened
is the whole time every time they ask
for truth they rearm themselves they
trained themselves they've been training
for this attack for two years while we
were letting them you know live
peacefully and so Hezbollah now I don't
want us to do the same mistake right now
they're throwing rockets at us but it's
like they're throwing little rocks and
if we don't uh attack if we don't do
anything they're going to go to bigger
stones and until they find a way to kill
us so I don't want us to do the same
mistake we did with Kamas by saying oh
it's not big Rockets they're just it's a
cry for help they're like a a kid that's
throwing a tum right but uh actually if
you show weakness you know in the Middle
East it's kill or be killed if you show
weakness the the shark smells the blood
in the water and they're going to come
to kill us so uh we did we made this
mistake with Hamas let's not make this
mistake with Hezbollah and if they keep
coming at us we got to strike hard um
I'm not saying open war with the whole
planet but when somebody is testing us
uh we need to show them you know we need
to cut it at the butt how long do you
plan to stay in Israel you mentioned you
live in Vegas uh if if if it were me I'd
probably take the first flight out if I
could uh but are you know do you do you
intend to stay for the foreseeable
future uh honestly I'm not sure if I can
be of help I I want to stay here uh when
it started you know I was already
supposed to be back I was supposed to be
for this week for a cousin's wedding and
it got
cancelled um but right now I'm staying I
want to see if they need the citizens to
fight I'm not a soldier I'm I'm an MMA
fighter as you know but if they need us
to defend our country if they need the
citizens to to to actively do it then
I'm here to do it and if I'm not needed
uh we'll see I I can imagine it would be
uh pretty scary uh if uh you were a
Hamas terrorist to see uh not just an
ordinary Soldier but also a a fairly
famous uh UFC fighter coming at you
there is a you know kind of an irony
about that because as you say you're
you're not a soldier you are a
professional fighter um what do you
think the likelihood is that the
citizenry and the civilians would be
called up right now I feel it's not
likely with the days going by you know
citizens had to fight don't get this
wrong citizens fought for their you know
for their homes uh when the terrorist
attack on Saturday October 7th uh it
took them military hours to get together
yeah that's a big fail no doubt about it
uh we got caught uh not ready but the
citizens were fighting and thank God you
know in America you have the Second
Amendment and uh in Israel uh we don't
have that same Amendment but we can
carry arms with a with a license and
people who live around Gaza many of them
have a gun and they fought off uh
thousands of terrorists and still we had
many dead but uh and you know those
terrorists they're not uh I don't call
them Fighters because if they would aim
for soldiers to kill soldiers then you
can say that's an act of War people kill
people in war but they were going after
civilians they were going after
teenagers that are ra they going after
babies in their cribs so absolutely zero
respect to this enemy uh and I'm very
happy that uh some civilians had weapons
and and shut them down
absolutely uh Natan thank you so much
for joining uh stay safe out there we we
will be praying for you and thanks for
joining the
show